do you still read everything that's one
has to know I stopped like two days ago
just two ok literally two days ago I
have you stop stop uhm I stopped reading
comments fully because because it was
ruining my life once again ruining her
life
yeah Billie Eilish is so over the haters
on social media and honestly do we blame
her
it's weird like the the the the cooler
things you get to do are the more people
hate you it's crazy
ok so this all went down in a new
interview with BBC Breakfast Billy
explained that the mean comments have
just become too much to handle with all
sorts of people leaving her hurtful
messages it's like way worse than it's
ever been right now it's insane that I
even have been reading comments up until
this point I should have stopped long
ago it's just the problem is I've always
wanted to stay in touch with the fans
and like keep talking to them and like
people have ruined that for me a
reminder Billy has nearly 55 million
followers on Instagram most of which
she's gained over the past year are you
ready for the next level of superstardom
no no I think I am honestly no I think I
I feel like I feel like I always happen
a little bit without really realizing it
your destiny and while she's definitely
hit that next level of superstardom she
doesn't have a solution to making things
easier when it comes to the internet how
do you make it better um I don't know
dude it's crazy
council culture is insane I mean that's
not what has been happening it's just
been like just the Internet's a bunch of
trolls you know and it's like the
problem is a lot of it's really funny
Billy's interview dropped just before
she took the stage at the 2020 Brit
Awards where she performed her new Bond
[Music]
she also delivered an empowered speech
at the award show where again she talked
about feeling the hate out there I also
want to just say something that I was
thinking like two seconds ago which is
I've I felt very hated recently and when
I was on the stage and I saw you guys
all smiling
um it genuinely made me want to cry and
I want to cry right now
ah I love her so much it bums me out
that she's feeling this way let me know
what you guys think of all of this and
for all the latest on Billy make sure
that you stick with all things et until
next time I'm Katie Krause
[Music]